So let's look at what's actually happening here to our two curves on this
coordinate plane, to create this black line over here. What I've drawn right
now, is a bunch of lines going from the x axis up to our curve. Or our line,
rather, f of x. What happens graphically when we want to add 3 to the length of
each of these lines, is that we're shifting them up. So that they start,
instead, at the line, y equals 3. If we connect these lines now, we end up with
a curve that looks just like our black line. Over there. So this line is
identical to the reddish one, just with every single point translated up 3
units. This is exactly what we were talking about with transformations in the
last lesson. Working with the same two functions as the last quiz, what if we
want to subtract one of these functions from the other? One of these three
graphs represents f minus g of x, and another one of them is g minus f of x.
Which one is which? In this top row of bubbles, please select f minus g. And in
the bottom row, please pick which one is g minus f. I wanted to keep the
functions written here for you. I'd recommend thinking about this graphically,
but if you need to work with the equations of the functions, and combine them
mathematically first, before you pick the graphs, that's also totally fine.